did you guys ever think that I'd be
doing something more with my life every
day you're walking to work you're curing
disease I'm not carrying disease what
about your video game you're the best at
it right welcome for the resistance
congratulations you are the Saviour
we've come down from the air 2162
everything that happens in the biotic
wars is really weird
the game is a recruitment and training
tools sent back in time to find the one
person with the skills to save us be the
first and only person to have beaten a
game that's the last starfighter it's
the exact same plot as the movie what's
a movie is this part of your arsenal
weaponry No No please don't that's a
sign oh my god I pay my only big coin
for that you're the key to stopping
Elias crushed Batman's research leads to
the annihilation of the entire human
race no he's working on her for herpes
if what we're fighting here a good fight
you're telling me that a cure for herpes
would bring down all of mankind oh [ __ ]
welcome to the resistance okay
we have to go back in time we killed
baby crows absolutely not you cannot
kill a baby bird vincible
no they are helpless and they're very
soft perfect easy kill if we can stop
them from getting herpes
he never creates the cure and we can
stop this whole cycle before it even
begins
we cock-blocking here's a little
something I brought with me from the
future
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you need to blend in time travel 101 you
tell me you've been back and forth
through time just to avoid killing yeah
the time travel was gonna be fun
this whole mission is insane what did
you think this was a game yeah because I
bought it at a game store with my
birthday month
yeah
[Music]
you
you